This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即便是 TWO%。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须这么做，仅仅因为你有这种能力。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的测试是你篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨 20 岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的……意味着什么。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s. Recently, I've been thinking quite a bit about envy and all the ways in which many of us in our 20s, myself included, never seem to be satisfied with what we have. Or in some ways, in constant competition with those around us who we perceive as being more accomplished, happier, more successful, maybe more materially blessed. It is such a mental trap to constantly be feeling not just inferior,
心理学的影响。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，继续收听新一期的节目，我们将一起剖析 20 多岁的心理学。最近，我一直在思考嫉妒心，以及在我们的 20 多岁（包括我自己）中，许多人似乎永远对现状不满意的方式。或者在某些方面，与我们周围那些我们认为更有成就、更快乐、更成功、也许在物质上更受眷顾的人进行着永无止境的竞争。不断感到自己不仅低人一等，这真是一个心理陷阱……
but this really intense sense of jealousy or longing for more and using other people as fuel for that insecurity, feeling like maybe they haven't worked as hard as us, that you deserve the life that they have, that it's unfair. And you know what? I'll admit part of my fascination with this at the moment is because I've been feeling a lot of envy recently. Envy that I think is wrongly placed and causing me a lot of dissatisfaction. And I think that envy is not a bad emotion if you take time to examine it. It's also one of those emotions that we rarely want to admit or reveal to other people or subconsciously to ourselves,
而是那种极其强烈的嫉妒感或对更多东西的渴望，把别人当作这种不安全感的燃料，觉得也许他们没有我们付出那么多努力，你理应过上他们那种生活，觉得这很不公平。你知道吗？我得承认，我目前对此如此着迷的一部分原因，是因为我最近也感到了很多嫉妒。我认为这种嫉妒放错了地方，给我带来了很多不满意。我认为，如果你花时间去审视嫉妒，它并不是一种坏情绪。这也是那种我们极少愿意承认或向别人透露，或者潜意识里对自己承认的情绪……
but I think it's really important to. And it's interesting because I think we can feel envious about almost anything about somebody's body, their clothes, their social status of someone's relationship, you know, your friend's dream job or your co-worker's promotion at work. you might initially feel happy for them, right? But there's also that pain of pain,
但我认为这真的很重要。这很有趣，因为我觉得我们可以对几乎任何事情感到嫉妒——别人的身材、他们的衣服、他们的社会地位、某人的恋爱关系，你知道的，你朋友的梦想工作，或者你同事在职场上的晋升。你最初可能会为他们感到高兴，对吧？但随之而来的还有那种痛苦……
as if your brain is saying, you know, why don't we have those things? That resentment, I think, really stops us from not just appreciating what we have, but from celebrating others. And then on the flip side of our experience of feeling envy is the experience of being envied by someone else. Maybe you have one of these friends or these peace, in your life, sometimes it can even be a parent or a family member in some cases,
就好像你的大脑在说，你知道的，为什么我们没有那些东西呢？我认为，这种怨恨真正阻止了我们，不仅让我们无法欣赏自己拥有的东西，也无法为他人庆祝。而在我们经历嫉妒的另一面，则是被别人嫉妒的体验。也许你的生活中就有这样的一些朋友或和平使者，有时在某些情况下甚至可能是父母或家庭成员……
who sees what you have and finds you undeserving or themselves more deserving, and they envy you for it. They refuse to celebrate your accomplishments. They are constantly scrutinizing and judging you, offering fake compliments or, you know, I think also attempting to compete with you as another huge one. That is also not a great feeling. And I think it's really fascinating. because all of us experience this, right? Every single one of us. But we never, we so infrequently speak about it because of the shame we feel towards what is at the end of the day a very anti-social emotion, a feeling that is derived
他们看到你拥有的东西，觉得你配不上，或者他们自己更配得上，因此他们嫉妒你。他们拒绝庆祝你的成就。他们不断地审视和评判你，说着虚伪的赞美，或者，你知道的，我也认为试图与你竞争也是非常明显的一点。这绝对也不是什么美妙的体验。我认为这真的很迷人。因为我们所有人都会经历这一切，对吧？我们每一个人。但我们从不，我们极少谈论它，因为对于终究是一种非常反社会的情绪，一种源自……的情感，我们感到羞耻。
primarily from our own insecurities. And these are insecurities that we definitely don't want to admit. You know, to admit our envy is to admit how we truly feel about ourselves, which is that we are lacking. Hence why someone else's successes, accomplishments have the capacity to make us feel so terrible about ourselves. So I think that that is why I wanted to direct our attention to this today. We owe it to ourselves to examine the, not just the origins of our envy, but the consequences it has the why behind envy. And how to, I guess, get to the point where we are happy and satisfied with what we have without needing to cause.
主要源于我们自己的不安全感。而这些不安全感是我们绝对不想承认的。你知道，承认我们的嫉妒，就是承认我们对自己的真实感觉，那就是我们有所欠缺。因此，别人的成功和成就才会有能力让我们对自己的感觉如此糟糕。所以我想，这就是为什么我想把大家的注意力引向今天这个话题。我们欠自己一个交代，不仅要审视我们嫉妒的根源，还要审视它带来的后果，以及嫉妒背后的原因。以及如何，我猜，达到这样一个境界：我们对我们所拥有的感到快乐和满足，而不需要强求……
constantly be like someone else. I think without needing to constantly compare, that is true freedom. And I think envy and the implicit comparison that comes along with it is such a thief of our joy, especially for those of us in our 20s, where someone else is always going to appear like they are doing better than you. We are all at such various different points of our journey. Some of us are further along. Some of us might feel behind, but it's not a race. So I think approaching that dynamic, approaching that nuance in everyone's different trajectory, is not actually going to help us, it's going to harm us, it's going to make us resentful people, it's going to make us bitter people. So I think understanding these reactions and the influence it has on our lives
不断地去模仿别人。我认为，无需不断地进行比较，这才是真正的自由。我认为嫉妒以及随之而来的隐含比较，是我们快乐的小偷，尤其是对于我们这些处于 20 多岁的人来说，总会有人看起来比你过得更好。我们都处在人生旅程的不同阶段。我们有些人走得更远一些。有些人可能会觉得自己落后了，但这不是一场赛跑。所以我觉得去迎合那种动态，去应对每个人不同轨迹中的细微差别，实际上并不能帮助我们，反而会伤害我们，把我们变成充满怨恨的人，变成刻薄的人。所以我认为理解这些反应以及它对我们生活的影响……
and our psychology is really important. So let's, of course, as we always do, start with the basics. envy is obviously an emotion that occurs when one person wants something that another person has. whether that thing is a material possession or perceived success or stature. Envy to me is one of those emotions that has never quite felt in isolation or on its own. It's almost always associated or consists of other elements like longing, like feelings of inferiority, ill will towards the envied person, resentment, guilt. When a person such as ourselves becomes envious, it is often you to some degree of dissatisfaction with yourself. In other words, envy occurs when a person believes
和我们的心理真的很重要。所以，就像我们一直做的那样，让我们从基础开始。嫉妒显然是一种这样的情绪：当一个人想要另一个人拥有的东西时就会产生。无论那个东西是物质财富、感知到的成功还是地位。对我来说，嫉妒是那种从未真正孤立存在或独自存在的情感。它几乎总是与渴望、自卑感、对被嫉妒者的恶意、怨恨、内疚等其他成分相关联或包含其中。当一个人（比如我们自己）产生嫉妒时，通常是因为你对自己的某种程度的不满意。换句话说，当一个人相信……时，嫉妒就会发生。
that having what another person has would increase their own happiness. So this person, this envied person is almost like a scapegoat for them, right? It's almost like instead of complaining or instead of looking to myself and feeling like I'm inferior for not having that, I'm going to tear this other person down and find ways in which they are undeserving in order to protect my own ego. So that's a more psychological definition. Envy is also commonly known as one of the seven deadly sins. And I want to highlight an important distinction here between envy and jealousy because I think they are often compared but also confused. They sometimes often feel the same. They look the same. we use them interchangeably, but whilst jealousy is defensive, it's kind of like an instinct
拥有别人拥有的东西会增加他们自己的幸福感。所以这个人，这个被嫉妒的人，对他们来说几乎就像一个替罪羊，对吧？这几乎就像是，与其抱怨，或者与其审视自己并因为没有那样东西而感到自卑，不如我去贬低这个人，找出他们不配拥有的地方，以此来保护我自己的自我。这是一个更具心理学定义的解释。嫉妒也被普遍认为是七宗罪之一。我想在这里强调嫉妒（Envy）和嫉妒（Jealousy）之间的重要区别，因为它们经常被对比，但也常常被混淆。它们有时感觉很相似。看起来也一样。我们经常交替使用它们，但嫉妒（Jealousy）是防御性的，它有点像一种本能……
to protect something that you already have, like feeling jealous of other people looking at your partner or jealous of other people in the workplace because you're worried they're going to be promoted above you. Envy is offensive. It's resentment over what someone else has that you like, like the promotion, like the perfect relationship, like they are with someone that you want to be with, you envy what they have, jealousy is protecting what you have. So I think this emotion is really deeply ingrained in our human psyche. It exists in all of us, in all societies,
为了保护你已经拥有的东西，比如嫉妒别人看你的伴侣，或者嫉妒职场上的其他人，因为你担心他们会升职到你头上。而嫉妒（Envy）是进攻性的。它是对别人拥有而你又喜欢的东西的怨恨，比如升职、完美的恋爱关系，或者他们和你想要在一起的人在一起，你嫉妒他们拥有的东西，而嫉妒（Jealousy）则是保护你拥有的东西。所以我觉得这种情绪在我们的现代人类心理中根深蒂固。它存在于我们所有人身上，存在于所有社会中……
and has so for generations and will continue to do so. And I think the universality of that kind of goes to show that it may have some purpose. even if we typically think of it as a very distasteful emotion, because something as reactive, as envy, as maybe aggressive, as envy, probably would have been eliminated from the kind of gene pool if it didn't serve some benefit. And we see that in how envy develops and evolves in us as individuals. Envy first really appears in really early stages of our development,
并且已经存在了世世代代，并将继续存在下去。我认为这种普遍性某种程度上表明，它可能有一些用途。即使我们通常认为它是一种非常令人反感的情绪，因为像嫉妒这样反应强烈、甚至具有攻击性的情绪，如果它没有带来某种好处，可能早就被从基因库中淘汰了。我们在嫉妒作为个体在我们体内发展和演变的过程中看到了这一点。嫉妒真正最初出现在我们发展的极早阶段……
especially when we are quite young children. if you've ever been around young kids, something you hear a lot is that everything is so unfair and that life is not fair and it's not fair that their friend or their sibling got the toy that they wanted or got the extra dessert or got more Christmas presents. Often this is really focused on material possessions and, you know, kids by nature, I would say, are very greedy and I think that highlights how perhaps envy is really derived from. greed. But as we get older, we learn to hide that instinct because it's unattractive. We learn that to be greedy is quite an ugly thing. But with children, they are yet to develop that social inhibition. So they really kind of reveal parts of our human nature that adults are better at hiding, that adults might not want to admit. So when we look at envy from an evolutionary perspective, I think that becomes a lot more clear.
特别是当我们还是小孩子的时候。如果你和幼小的孩子们在一起过，你会经常听到的一句话是，一切都太不公平了，生活太不公平了，他们的朋友或兄弟姐妹得到了他们想要的玩具，或者得到了额外的甜点，或者得到了更多的圣诞礼物。通常这非常专注于物质财富，而且，你知道的，孩子们天生就是贪婪的，我认为这突显了嫉妒也许是如何源自……贪婪。但随着我们年龄的增长，我们学会了隐藏这种本能，因为它并不讨人喜欢。我们了解到贪婪是一件相当丑陋的事情。但对于孩子们来说，他们还没有培养出这种社交抑制能力。所以他们确实揭示了人类天性中成年人更能隐藏、成年人可能不想承认的部分。因此，当我们从进化的角度来看待嫉妒时，我认为这会变得更加清晰。
You guys know I love my history deep dives. I love to explore how current emotions have their origins and some prehistoric instincts. And I think envy is a really, really good example of this. I saw someone explain this really well in an article. Essentially, in the past, when we were developing as a species, a lot of the resources that we needed to not just survive but thrive, things like food, materials to build homes, fertile land, at places that were secure, even the more developed where we got wealth and money, those resources were really limited. And so that created a natural competition, not just between individuals, but groups of people. And that competition is what created envy and also what created greed.
你们知道我喜欢深入研究历史。我喜欢探索当今的情感如何起源于一些史前本能。我认为嫉妒就是一个非常非常好的例子。我看到有人在一篇文章中很好地解释了这一点。本质上，在过去，当我们作为一个物种在发展时，许多我们不仅需要生存而且需要繁荣的资源——像食物、建造房屋的材料、肥沃的土地、安全的地方，甚至是更发达的我们获得财富和金钱的地方——这些资源真的很有限。这就造成了一种自然的竞争，不仅在个人之间，在人类群体之间也是如此。正是这种竞争创造了嫉妒，也创造了贪婪。
it benefited us to be more aware of what others had and what we may have lacked in order to motivate us to get those things, in order to motivate us to kind of collect and hoard more of those vital resources. That has also been influenced by culture. If you were brought up in a family or an environment that placed a really huge emphasis on success and therefore subsequently competing with others, you are more prone to feeling envious just as a basis of your upbringing. You're more prone to feeling like you're falling behind, maybe feeling insecure about your achievements,
对我们来说，更多地意识到别人拥有什么以及我们可能缺少什么是有好处的，这可以激励我们去获得这些东西，激励我们去收集和囤积更多这些至关重要的资源。这也受到了文化的影响。如果你在一个家庭或环境中长大，这个家庭或环境对成功以及随之而来的与他人竞争给予了极大的重视，那么仅仅基于你的成长背景，你就会更容易感到嫉妒。你更容易觉得自己正在落后，也许会对自己的成就感到不安全……
and therefore projecting that emotion onto others. That is reflected in what psychologists have proposed are the conditions of envy. There are three of these. Firstly, the person we envy is normally someone who we feel related to in some way. for example, they are a friend, they are a family member, they are an acquaintance, or in the case of people that we see online or on social media, they have to be individuals who we feel somewhat similar to in terms of things like age, gender, ethnicity, certain personal characteristics. For example, we are much more likely to envy the wealth and privilege of someone like Bella Hadid or Taylor Swift if you are a woman in your 20s compared to a billionaire like Bill Gates or Rupert Murdoch because we feel like we already share some of the same qualities as people
从而把这种情绪投射到别人身上。心理学家提出的嫉妒条件反映了这一点。其中有三个。首先，我们嫉妒的人通常是我们觉得在某种程度上有联系的人。例如，他们是朋友、家庭成员、熟人，或者对于我们在网上或社交媒体上看到的人来说，他们必须是在年龄、性别、种族、某些个人特征等方面让我们觉得有些相似的个人。例如，如果你是一个 20 多岁的女性，与像比尔·盖茨或鲁伯特·默多克这样的亿万富翁相比，我们更有可能嫉妒像贝拉·哈迪德或泰勒·斯威夫特这样的人的财富和特权，因为我们觉得我们已经与这些人分享了一些相同的品质……
like Bella or Taylor. Yes, we may not be mega famous, we may not be millionaires, but we do feel similar to them in terms of our certain personal characteristics. And so they become a good point of comparison for what we are maybe lacking or missing out on. So that really links to this point. Envy is essentially derived from social comparison. It develops when we instinctively compare ourselves to others. Often, once again, those people who are most like us, but also those who we find ourselves to be inferior to. And although this process is a natural one, I think it's also been deeply exacerbated by recent technological advancements like social media. We now constantly see the achievements and positive life experiences of everyone we know and everyone we don't know
比如贝拉或泰勒。是的，我们可能不是超级名流，我们可能不是百万富翁，但在某些个人特征方面，我们确实觉得与她们相似。因此，她们成为了一个很好的比较点，让我们看到我们可能缺乏或错过了什么。所以这确实与这一点联系在一起。嫉妒本质上源于社会比较。当我们本能地把自己和他人进行比较时，它就会发展起来。通常，同样是那些最像我们的人，但也是那些我们发现自己不如他们的人。尽管这个过程是一个自然的过程，但我认为它也被最近的技术进步（如社交媒体）大大加剧了。我们现在不断地看到我们认识的每个人和不认识的每个人的成就和积极的生活经历……
on platforms like Instagram or even LinkedIn for my professional listeners. And when we are bombarded with this, when we are constantly seeing, I hate the term highlight reel, but that's really what it is, a highlight reel, we start to feel envious. Because we know our life as a series of not just achievements, but also imperfections, but we don't see other people's lives like that because they don't give us the option to view them in that way. They're not going to post on their LinkedIn or on their Instagram, like, I'll have a really tough conversation with my boss today might be getting fired or like me and my boyfriend broke up.
在 Instagram 这样的平台上，甚至对于我的专业听众来说还有 LinkedIn。当我们被这些狂轰滥炸时，当我们不断地看到——我讨厌“精彩集锦”这个词，但事实确实如此，就是一个精彩集锦——我们开始感到嫉妒。因为我们知道我们的生活是一系列不仅有成就，还有不完美的生活，但我们并没有那样看待别人的生活，因为他们没有给我们以这种方式去观察他们的选择。他们不会在他们的 LinkedIn 或 Instagram 上发帖说：“我和老板进行了一次非常艰难的谈话，我可能会被解雇”或者“我和我男友分手了”。
I feel like normal ever love me. Like they're not posting that. They're posting the things that are going to make them look good. But yet we wonder why we are not like that perfect version, why we are not as experienced or as successful or we don't look like them or we're not as happy as them because that is constantly presented to us front and center everywhere we look. The second condition of envy is that we can really only envy what we desire. I know that sounds fairly obvious, but obviously we cannot envy someone's bad luck. We cannot envy someone's shortcomings or misgivings. That's because envy is once again at the end of the day about what we lack. We are the ones with the perceived bad luck or the shortcomings or the deficits. So we don't envy this. We don't envy this
我觉得正常人永远不会爱我。就像他们不会发这些一样。他们发的是那些能让自己看起来很好的事情。然而，我们却在纳闷，为什么我们不像那个完美的版本，为什么我们没有那么经验丰富，或者没有那么成功，或者我们看起来不像他们，或者我们没有他们那么快乐，因为这些东西不断地被呈现在我们面前的中心位置，无论我们看哪里都是如此。嫉妒的第二个条件是，我们其实只能嫉妒我们所渴望的东西。我知道这听很显而易见，但显然我们不能嫉妒别人的厄运。我们不能嫉妒别人的缺点或过失。那是因为嫉妒归根结底还是关于我们所缺少的东西。我们才是那些有着感知到的厄运、缺点或不足的人。所以我们不嫉妒这个。我们不嫉妒这个……
other person simply because of what they have. We envy them because we don't have it. And we adopt the attitude that this one quality or one possession or one privilege is what is going to make our lives better. That is really important to remember. The pain of envy is caused not just by the desire for the advantages of others per se, but our feelings of inferiority and frustration that is mirrored back to us by someone else's success. And it's that insecurity that makes envy such an emotionally painful experience at times. I think about this a lot in the sense of the people that we can't help but dislike on social media, even if we've never met them, social media influences, creators, whatever, these are the people that we might quote unquote hate follow. And that's a term
另一个人仅仅是因为他们拥有什么。我们嫉妒他们是因为我们没有。并且我们采取这样一种态度：正是这种品质、这种Possession或这种特权会让我们的生活变得更好。记住这一点真的很重要。嫉妒带来的痛苦不仅是由对他人优势本身的渴望引起的，也是由别人的成功折射出的我们的自卑感和挫败感引起的。正是这种不安全感使得嫉妒有时成为一种情感上痛苦的体验。每当我想到我们在社交媒体上忍不住讨厌的人时，我就会想得很多，即使我们从未见过他们，社交媒体网红、创作者等等，这些人可能就是我们所谓的“含恨关注”的对象。这是一个术语……
I actually learned the other day. It's this case where we know that their content is going to make us feel bad about ourselves. It's going to elicit envy, but we can't help but keep watching and observing. They appear to live perfect lives. They have everything we wanted. Maybe the dream job, the curated outfits, the overseas trips, the friendship circle. Instead of admiring them for it, it makes us so insecure that we can't help but be reactive and judge them. And it's interesting because envy of this sort really disguises itself because we know that it's not socially acceptable to outright say, I actually really don't like this person and I have no good reason for it
我实际上前几天才了解到。这种情况是，我们知道他们的内容会让我们对自己的感觉变糟糕。它会引发嫉妒，但我们又忍不住继续观看和观察。他们似乎过着完美的生活。他们拥有我们想要的一切。也许是梦想的工作、精心搭配的服装、海外旅行、朋友圈。我们没有去钦佩他们，反而感到如此不安全，以至于忍不住做出反应并评判他们。很有趣的是，这种嫉妒会伪装自己，因为我们知道公开说“我其实真的很讨厌这个人，而且我没有任何充分的理由，除了我怨恨他们的成功”在社交上是不可接受的……
other than that I resent their success. You know, we cannot say that because people are going to look at us funny and be like, what is their deal? So instead it gives rise to a lot more subtle. defensive reactions like character defamation, sarcasm, snobbery, nitpicking, trying to find some flaw or reason that we or others perhaps shouldn't admire this person. We see that with online personas once again all the time where we implicitly kind of impose some sort of moral high horse. Like, you know, yeah, sure, sure that person has a million dollars and people think they're
你知道，我们不能那样说，因为人们会用奇怪的眼神看着我们，心想：这人到底怎么回事？因此，它引发了更多微妙的防御性反应，比如人格诋毁、讽刺、势利、挑剔，试图寻找某种我们或其他人也许不应该钦佩这个人的缺陷或理由。我们再次在网络人设中一直看到这一点，我们下意识地强加某种道德制高点。就像，“你知道，是的，当然，那个人有一百万美元，人们认为他们很……”
great, but at least I wasn't handed everything in life. Or, yeah, sure, they have a private jet, but that is so bad for the environment and at least I'm sustainable. Anything to simultaneously justify our envy, our dislike, whilst also protecting our character. So concluding that someone isn't deserving is one of the ways that we do that. I see that all the time. And you know what? Sometimes that might be fair. That might be fair. This person might be like an or whatnot, but it doesn't eliminate the fact that at the end of the day, you are still the one who was reacting from a place of insecurity. You secretly still want what they have, even if at the same time you're telling yourself that it's a problem. I think envy is intriguing in that way because
棒，但至少我不是生来就拥有一切的。”或者，“是的，当然，他们有私人飞机，但这太不利于环保了，至少我是可持续发展的。”任何事情都可以同时用来证明我们的嫉妒、我们的厌恶，同时又保护我们的人格。因此，断定某人不配拥有是我们做到这一点的方法之一。我一直看到这种情况。你知道吗？有时这可能是公平的。这可能是公平的。这个人可能是一个混蛋什么的，但这并不能消除这样一个事实：归根结底，你仍然是从不安全感出发做出反应的那个人。你暗地里仍然想要他们拥有的东西，即使与此同时你还在告诉自己这是一个问题。我认为嫉妒在这一点上非常引人入胜，因为……
when we see something that we desire that we believe we should be entitled to, we often don't consider the full picture. We don't consider the effort that may have gone. into creating that dream life or the sacrifices or maybe even the downsides, it's so one-dimensional to us. Often, our envy convinces us that everything someone else has, everything that we want, that they have, has come to them purely by chance and that it was luck. And maybe in some ways, that is true when we think about, obviously nepotism was one I said before or generational wealth. but in many ways it's a lot more complex than that. But by blinding us to that,
当我们看到我们渴望的、我们认为我们应该拥有的东西时，我们往往看不到全貌。我们没有考虑到创造那种梦想生活可能付出的努力、牺牲，甚至可能是缺点，这对我们来说太单一了。通常，我们的嫉妒让我们确信，别人拥有的所有东西、我们想要的所有东西，都是纯粹靠机缘巧合降临到他们身上的，那纯粹是运气。也许在某些方面，当我们想到任人唯亲（我之前说过的一个词）或世代财富时，这是真的。但在许多方面，它要复杂得多。但是，通过让我们对这一点视而不见……
by blinding us to that fact that this person actually maybe did give a whole lot more than we can see for that life, it allows our envy to become self-sustaining and it feels justified. And when that envy is justified, it's chronic. And it leads to a pretty unhappy life. To constantly feel less, to feel like others have more, to feel dissatisfied in a state of comparison or competition is a really dark place to be in. And it has a lot of secondary consequences for our relationships, not just with others,
通过让我们对“这个人实际上可能为那种生活付出了远超我们所能看到的巨大努力”这一事实视而不见，它使我们的嫉妒变得能够自我维持，并且感觉是正当的。当这种嫉妒显得正当合理时，它就是慢性的。这会导致相当不幸福的生活。不断感到自己不如人，觉得别人拥有更多，在比较或竞争的状态中感到不满，是一个非常黑暗的处境。这会对我们的人际关系产生许多次要后果，不仅是对他人……
but our relationship with ourself and with our own sense of self-worth. So I think it's incredibly important to explore how we can kind of befriend that green-eyed monster. We have to make friends with it. and we have to stop comparing ourselves to others. I know that is easier said than done, but I'm going to give you some tips for doing just that, and we're going to talk about it a lot more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs
还有我们与自己的关系以及我们自身的自我价值感。所以我认为，探索我们如何能够与那个“绿眼怪物”交朋友是极其重要的。我们必须与它交朋友。我们必须停止与他人进行我知道这说起来容易做起来难，但在接下来的短暂休息之后，我将给你一些这样做的秘诀，我们将对此进行更多的讨论。2%。那是选择走楼梯的人所占的比例……
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strain. modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
当有自动扶梯可用时。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们紧张的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信籽油本质上是发炎性的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是 TWO%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什他妈的和勒尔·金有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目……
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black kids. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
我认为对黑人儿童没有比这更重要的年份了。人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的一年。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主播、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐……
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个东西，却还在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要……
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kea Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
当你活在世上时，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你篡改了这次特定的测试两次，而塞尔确保了测试一次。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, and sell insured the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻……
Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Envying others is not going to give you what they have. It will not help you get any closer to your goals or your dreams, unfortunately. it's not going to make you happier. Your envy is also not going to hurt that person
劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。嫉妒别人并不会让你得到他们拥有的东西。不幸的是，它不会帮助你离你的目标或梦想更近一步。它也不会让你更快乐。你的嫉妒也不会伤害那个人……
whose success you really long for, and it's certainly not going to make you many friends. I think envy, and with that competition, is such an insidious feeling because we may feel like we're doing something about our fears and insecurities by reflecting them onto the other person, but it also normally manifests in behaviors
你真正渴望其成功的那个人，而且它肯定不会为你赢得许多朋友。我认为嫉妒以及随之而来的竞争是一种如此阴险的感觉，因为我们可能会觉得自己通过将恐惧和不安全感投射到另一个人身上来做点什么来应对它们，但它通常也会表现为自我毁灭的行为……
that self-sabotage, that sabotage not, just our own efforts, but also the relationships we have with other people, where we begin to express resentment, we tear them down, sometimes without even realizing it. That's the important thing. You know, I don't think anyone wants to be an envious person. It's just that it has a strange influence on how we see ourselves and therefore how we treat others. I think that's the part of it. It often is so out of our control, probably because it does originate in a lot of self-doubt and limiting beliefs, which are not always operating at the front of our mind because of the fact that
不仅破坏我们自己的努力，也破坏我们与其他人的人际关系，在那里我们开始表现出怨恨，我们贬低他们，有时甚至没有意识到。这才是重要的事情。你知道，我认为没有人想成为一个嫉妒的人。只是它对我们如何看待自己以及因此如何对待他人有着奇怪的影响。我认为这就是其中的一部分。它通常完全超出了我们的控制范围，可能是因为它确实源于大量的自我怀疑和限制性信念，而这些信念并不总是由于……而处于我们思维的前沿。
they are too painful to acknowledge. You know, feeling inadequate is not something that our brain wants to constantly remind us of. Instead, it will compare and use that as kind of a proxy. It's a knee-jerk reaction to not feeling that we are good enough. So how are we, you and I, going to stop feeling envious? and better yet, how are we actually going to project gratitude and joy for what we have regardless of whether someone else happens to have more? Envy is kind of a question of attitude, and it's an attitude, a mindset that is a natural opposite to gratitude and generosity. When we come across someone who is better or more successful than we are, and we experience
它们太痛苦而无法承认。感到不够好并不是我们的大脑想要不断提醒我们的事情。相反，它会进行比较并将其用作某种代理。这是对感觉自己不够好的一种膝跳反应。那么你和我将如何停止感到嫉妒呢？更好的是，我们究竟该如何对我们所拥有的东西表达感激和喜悦，而不管别人碰巧拥有更多？嫉妒有点像一个态度问题，这种态度或心态与感激和慷慨是天然相反的。当我们遇到一个比我们更好或更成功的人时，我们经历了……
that typical pain, we get to choose where. we are going to react from a place of comparison and inferiority or respond with genuine happiness for the other person and kind of a mutual gratitude for what we have, relying on our empathy in those moments. Sometimes when I feel like I need to compare, instead I try and ask myself the following questions. If this was me, how would I like to be celebrated for my successes? How can I make this person feel really amazing about themselves. And then I also try and be like, what has led this person to this moment? What has given them their success? I had this realization the other day, and maybe it's not mind-blowing for you. Maybe I'm late to the party. But I realize that I really do
那种典型的痛苦，我们可以选择我们在哪里……从比较和自卑的角度做出反应，还是以对另一个人的真诚高兴以及对我们所拥有的东西的相互感激做出回应，在那些时刻依靠我们的同理心。有时，当我觉得自己需要进行比较时，我会试着问自己以下问题。如果这是我，我希望如何因为我的成功而受到庆祝？我怎样才能让这个人对他们自己感觉真的很棒？然后我也会试着想：是什么引领这个人走到这一刻的？是什么赋予了他们成功？我前几天有了这样一个认识，也许对你来说这并不是什么惊天动地的启发。也许我后知后觉。但我意识到我确实……
get to choose how I feel. I am in charge of my own emotions and how they impact my behavior. And for a long time, I was like, envy is this uncontrollable little devil that I have no, no say in. It just comes about every now and again and I just have to live with it. I think in those moments when I was experiencing envy and making myself feel bad, I decided that I can reverse that feeling by talking to my envy, talking to myself. almost as a third party, almost having like a solo pep talk or advice session where I speak to my ego, the part of me that feels hurt, almost like a child. And it feels embarrassing to say it out loud. But I started doing this thing where I was basically like, Gemma, is this really benefiting you right now? Is this making you feel better? No. So why are you allowing yourself to have
可以选择我的感觉。我掌控着自己的情绪以及它们如何影响我的行为。很长一段时间里，我都觉得：嫉妒是一个无法控制的小魔鬼，我对此毫无发言权。它只是每隔一段时间就会出现，我必须接受它。我认为在那些我经历嫉妒并让自己感觉糟糕的时刻，我决定可以通过与我的嫉妒对话、与自己对话来逆转那种感觉。几乎就像作为第三方，几乎就像进行一次个人的打气或建议会话，我在其中与我的自我对话，与我内心感到受伤的部分对话，就像对一个小孩子说话一样。大声说出来觉得很尴尬。但我开始这样做，我基本上是说：“杰玛，这真的对你有好处吗？这让你感觉更好吗？没有。那你为什么允许自己有……”
this thought. You can replace that with a better thought. You can replace it by choosing to focus on what you do have. And I think this is basically a form of mindfulness whereby we pay attention, full attention to what is going on within us and also outside of you without judgment. You pay attention to what is triggering you, what is creating this feeling, whilst also not needing to be invested in it. You know, you can feel envy without needing to respond and instead pause, make a mental list of all the ways that you are fulfilled, that you are secure, that you have a lot more than other people do. Remember this, please, please remember this if you remember only one thing from this episode. You are not an envious or bad person just because you experience envy.
这种想法。你可以用一个更好的想法取而代之。你可以通过选择专注于你确实拥有的东西来取代它。我认为这基本上是一种正念的形式，通过这种形式，我们全神贯注于我们内心以及你外部正在发生的事情，而不带评判。你关注是什么在触发你，是什么在产生这种感觉，同时又不需要投入过多的情感。你知道，你可以感受到嫉妒而无需做出回应，相反可以停下来，在心中列出一个清单，列出你在所有方面是如何被满足的、你是如何有安全感的、你拥有的比其他人多得多。请记住这一点，如果你从这集节目中只记住了一件事，请记住这一点。你并不是一个嫉妒的人或坏人，仅仅因为你经历了嫉妒。
No emotion is inherently bad or evil. They all have a place. And I think Envy's purpose in this sense is to serve as a reminder of what you actually aspire for. Because you wouldn't be jealous of this person if you didn't implicitly desire what they had created for themselves. So let it serve as a reminder of your goals and your vision for your life. You know, one of your friends has just bought their first home, has their dream relationship, is getting their PhD, it's just like killing it. You want that.
没有任何一种情绪本身是坏的或邪恶的。它们都有其存在的意义。我认为嫉妒在这个意义上的目的，是作为一个提醒，提醒你实际上渴望什么。因为如果你没有潜意识里渴望他们为自己创造的东西，你就不会嫉妒这个人。所以让它成为对你的目标和人生愿景的提醒。你知道，你的一个朋友刚刚买下了他们的第一套房，拥有了他们梦寐以求的恋爱关系，正在攻读博士学位，简直太棒了。你想要那个。
That's why you're envious. So make it happen. Also, there is always going to be someone who is better than you, quote unquote, better than you, who is doing more, who has more than you, who possesses something that you don't have, but you deeply want. And that is not a reflection of your character. Not everything that other people do says something about yourself or your inherent worth as a person. for every person that you admire and you may feel envious of, they also have someone that they think about
这就是你嫉妒的原因。所以让它发生吧。此外，总会有人比你更好，所谓“比你更好”、做得更多、拥有什么都比你多、拥有你没有但你深深渴望的东西。这并不是对你人格的反映。并不是其他人做的每一件事都说明了你自己或你作为一个人固有的价值。对于你钦佩并可能感到嫉妒的每一个人，也有某个人是他们这样看待的……
in that sense as well. And I also promise you that there is someone somewhere out there who feels that way about you. We often don't think about that. We don't think that we are worthy of the admiration and maybe even the jealousy that we are, you know, at times have for others. You know, the same ways that we direct those feelings to someone else, we feel envious. We feel of them is the same way that people do that for us. It's like this weird circular hierarchy where there is a constant wheel of things that people want that you might not have whilst you're looking at someone else and they're wanting what you have. And no one is ever fully satisfied in that equation. So when we insist on engaging in what is known as upward social comparison in these
从这个意义上说也是如此。我也向你保证，某个地方一定有人对你抱有这种感觉。我们往往不会去想这一点。我们不认为自己配得上钦佩，甚至不认为自己配得上那种我们有时对别人产生的情绪（也许甚至是嫉妒）。你知道，我们把这些感觉引向别人的方式，我们感到嫉妒的方式。我们对他们感到……的方式，正是别人对我们的方式。这就像是一个奇怪的循环阶层，这里有一个永恒的欲望之轮，别人想要你可能没有的东西，而当你看着别人的时候，他们又想要你拥有的东西。在这条方程式中，没有人是完全满意的。所以当我们坚持参与所谓的向上社会比较时，在这些……
moments of only ever thinking about who is doing better than us, we never truly feel grateful for what we have. Additionally, by reacting with envy in those situations, we prevent ourselves from learning from those who know or understand more than we do. So we keep ourselves in a place of self-pity, of maybe resentment and definitely stagnation, because our pride would rather compare than learn. I'm going to say that one time. Our pride would rather compare than learn. But when you react with joy and respect for this person. When you begin to see them as someone that you can learn from, you allow yourself to be inspired and you allow yourself to be taught and you actually gain more for yourself than you would have if you just sat there and had a bit of a pity party. Or if you sat there
时刻只想着谁比我们过得更好，我们便永远无法真正感激我们所拥有的。此外，在那种情况下用嫉妒做出反应，会让我们失去向那些比我们懂得更多、理解更深的人学习的机会。因此，我们让自己陷入一种自我怜悯、也许是怨恨、绝对是停滞不前的境地，因为我们的傲慢宁愿去比较也不愿去学习。这句话我要再说一遍。我们的傲慢宁愿去比较也不愿去学习。但是，当你对这个人报以喜悦和尊重时。当你开始把他们看作你可以向其学习的人时，你就会允许自己受到启发，允许自己接受教育，而你实际为自己获得的收益，会比你只是坐在那里自怨自艾要多得多。或者如果你坐在那里
and let yourself be controlled by an emotion that actually isn't allowing you to progress further. Additionally, when you feel a spike of envy, this psychologist from the UCLA Department of Psychology, she had some really good advice for this. She said, question the hell out of it. Before taking the source of your envy at face value, recognize that a lot of what we see online, even in real life, is not the full truth. People want to impress other people. And that means that sometimes they They conceal, they tell white lies. They try and make it seem like they're doing better than they are. You know, maybe you are really envious of the fact that a lot of the people you went to high school with or uni with have these great careers while you're still chugging your way at university.
任由自己被一种实际上不允许你进一步发展的情绪所控制。此外，当你感到嫉妒心突然爆发时，这位来自加州大学洛杉矶分校心理学系的心理学家对此有一些非常好的建议。她说，好好地去质疑它。在全盘接受你嫉妒的根源之前，认识到我们在网上、甚至在现实生活中看到的大多数东西并非全部真相。人们都想给别人留下深刻印象。这意味着有时他们会掩饰，会说善意的谎言。他们试图让自己看起来比实际过得更好。你知道，也许你真的很嫉妒那些和你一起上高中或大学的人有着光鲜亮丽的职业，而你还在大学里苦苦挣扎。
But what if the real story was, you know, these people actually haven't taken a day off for like six months. Like these people are working like 70, 80 hour weeks. And they're looking at you being like, gosh, I'm so envious. that she's still at university, that he's still studying. Other people's lives are never exactly the way that they're presented. Because once again, we all want to display that really carefully curated version of who we are. You know, a lot of us are really, really messy. I think that's important to remember.
但如果真实的故事是，你知道，这些人实际上已经连续六个月没有休假了。这些人每周工作70到80个小时。他们看着你，心里想，天哪，我太嫉妒了，她还在上大学，他还在学习。别人的生活绝不像他们呈现的那样完美。因为同样地，我们都想展示我们真实自我的那个精心策划的版本。你知道，我们中的很多人其实都非常非常糟糕。我认为记住这一点很重要。
And I think about this all the time in terms of my last relationship, when my friends would kind of be like, oh, like, we want what you have. and like, you guys are perfect for each other. And that was so far from the truth. That was so far from the truth. But I didn't want to tell them that. I didn't want anyone to see the whole picture. So I think the reminder here is that envy is about wanting something that someone else has,
我总是会想到我上一段恋情时的情景，当时我的朋友们会说，哦，天哪，我们想要拥有你所拥有的，你们两个简直是天生一对。而事实远非如此。事实远非如此。但我不想告诉他们这些。我不想让任何人看到全貌。所以这里的提醒是，嫉妒是想要得到别人拥有的东西，
but also probably not really understanding what that fully means, or not really having the full picture. Finally, like I said before, you do get to choose how. how you feel. And if envy is part of who you are at the moment, if it's interrupting the pursuit of your goals or making you doubt your progress, maybe it's making you copy what someone else is doing, trying to be more like them. My biggest advice, and I've said it before, I'm going to say it again, you can remove that trigger. You can unfollow the people who make you doubt yourself and your journey and are a source of envy. Go to your Instagram right now or your
但可能也没有真正理解那意味着什么，或者没有看到全貌。最后，就像我之前说过的，你的感受是由你来选择的。如果嫉妒目前是你的一部分，如果它打断了你对目标的追求，或者让你怀疑自己的进展，也许它让你去模仿别人的行为，试图变得更像他们。我最大的建议，我已经说过，还要再说一遍，你可以移除那个导火索。你可以取关那些让你怀疑自己和你的旅程、成为嫉妒之源的人。现在就打开你的Instagram或者你的
TikTok or your Twitter, whatever it is, and purge. It is not worth it. Trust me, at the very least, you can mute these people. And this will have the dual benefit of lessening your experience of envy so that you can manage it in a productive way. And also reducing how often you question your own path and your authenticity. You know, sometimes we always want to, we think that the perfect, like someone else has figured out the perfect equation for our dream life. But the thing is that it's our dream life. They're living their dream life. It's going to be different. I know social comparison can be so impossibly hard, especially in this decade where everyone is further along or at a different stage. There's so much room to feel like you are not good enough
TikTok或Twitter，无论是什么，进行一次大扫除吧。这不值得。相信我，最起码，你可以将这些人静音。这会带来双重好处：既能减少你对嫉妒的体验，从而让你能以富有成效的方式处理它，又能减少你质疑自身道路和真实性的频率。你知道，有时我们总是渴望，我们认为完美的东西——就像别人已经找到了我们梦想生活的完美公式。但问题是，那是我们的梦想生活。他们过的是他们自己的梦想生活。这是会有所不同的。我知道社交比较有时会难到不可思议，在这个每个人都走得更远或处在不同阶段的十年里尤其如此。有太多的空间让人觉得你还不够好
or you need to feel envious of other successes. But as your final reminder for the day, I want you to remember that your path is completely unique. And you never know when it's going to be your time. You never know when things will suddenly transform for you or switch. And the more time you spend devoting all that energy that you could spend feeling envious and instead choose to invest it in your goals, the greater the outcomes are going to be. like genuinely like do a physical head pivot and be like I can spend my time looking right and left at what everyone else is doing but I'm not spending a lot of time looking forward if I'm doing that I'm spending
或者你需要去嫉妒别人的成功。但作为今天最后的提醒，我想让你记住，你的道路是完全独特的。你永远不知道什么时候会轮到你的时代。你永远不知道什么时候事情会突然为你发生转变或切换。你花在感受嫉妒上的精力越多，转而选择将其投资在你的目标上，结果就会越好。就像真正地转动一下头部说，我可以花时间向左向右看别人在做什么，但如果我这样做，我就没有花很多时间向前看，我花在
way more time seeing what other people what they think is right and seeing what other people think is good and cool and what their successes are that is the easiest way to get distracted from your own goals So I really hope that you have enjoyed this episode. There is no shame around envy. I want to say that again. We all experience this. I experience this. It is so biological and evolutionary.
看别人认为什么是对的、看别人认为什么是好是酷的、看别人的成功上的时间要多得多，那是从你自己的目标中分心的最快方式。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一期节目。嫉妒并不可耻。我想再次强调这一点。我们所有人都会经历这种情绪。我也会经历。它是如此符合生物学和进化论。
It is so deeply imprinted in our DNA to want what others have. But hopefully this provided you with some kind of insights into why that is and some tips, hopefully, some knowledge on where to go from here and how to really. Just be grateful and happy for what you have and the journey that you are on without needing to look at other people to validate that for you. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Thank you for putting up with my voice. I know it is still quite nasally. I'm still a little bit sick. So please bear with me.
想要别人拥有的东西深深地印刻在我们的DNA中。但希望这能为你提供一些见解，让你明白为什么会这样，并提供一些建议和知识，告诉你接下来该去往何方，以及如何真正地去感激和享受你所拥有的东西以及你正在经历的旅程，而无需依赖别人来向你证实这一点。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。谢谢你们包容我的声音。我知道它听起来还是带有很重的鼻音。我还在生病。所以请多多包容。
It's slowly getting better. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to see behind the scenes, what we're doing, what we're up to, please feel free to follow me at That Psychology Podcast. Or you can follow my personal Instagram at That Jemis Pegg. We would love to have you back. Make sure you're following. And we will see you next week for another episode on Tuesday. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
它正在慢慢好转。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想看看幕后花絮，看看我们在做什么，在忙些什么，请随时在That Psychology Podcast关注我。或者你也可以关注我的个人Instagram，账号是That Jemis Pegg。我们非常欢迎你的回归。确保你已经关注了。我们下周二的另一期节目见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
我剖析了我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA percent。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。在它成为一个疯狂的年份之前。这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's, experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行真正无法在任何地方安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。多少男人身披一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个
capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to love trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听love trapped播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。